Avalaaaanche!
On an asteroid?
Hey guys, Amy here for DNews.
Avalanches aren’t exactly a big killer of
humans, but they’re still a hazard for skiers,
climbers, bikers… basically anyone who does
any sport in secluded areas on mountains.
But one avalanche scientists have managed
to predict will be both super cool and super
safe for all extreme sports fans: an avalanche
on an asteroid.
Scientists have been tracking a football field–sized
asteroid called Apophis, and it turns out
this space rock is going to make a very close
fly by the Earth -- it will come within 22,000
miles of our planet -- in 2029.
It’s not going to affect us or our planet
at all, but the Earth’s gravity will take
its toll on the asteroid, triggering a series
of small avalanches.
Scientists are basing this avalanche prediction
on pictures Japan’s Hayabusa spacecraft
took of an Apophis-sized asteroid called Itokawa.
Itokawa, it turns out, isn’t a solid mass
but a clump of rocky debris held loosely together
by gravity.
It’s likely Apophis is the same, not a solid
mass but a clump of debris.
Computer modeling revealed how a loosely shaped
asteroid might behave passing by our planet.
Scientist placed virtual piles of sand on
the surface of a model asteroid with roughly
the same shape and dimensions as Apophis.
They factored in the asteroids own gravity,
the tidal forces from the Earth, and centrifugal
force from the asteroid’s rotation, and
other inertial forces.
Then they measured the effects on the sand
piles.
The results confirmed that the Earth's tidal
forces will be strong enough during the encounter
to cause tiny avalanches on the asteroid.
So while the view from up close on Apophis
might be awesome during the close pass, it
dangerous, and unfortunately we won’t see
much of anything from our Earthly vantage
point.
These avalanches are going to move extremely
slowly thanks to the asteroid’s low gravity.
And really, the shifting rock is probably
just going to keep Apophis looking young.
It’s going to resurface the asteroid sort
of like a microdermabrasion treatment.
Still, pretty neat that we can predict an
avalanche on an asteroid five years in advance,
eh?
Let us know in the comments below or you can
catch me on Twitter as @astVintageSpace.
And don’t forget to subscribe for more DNews
every day of the week.